yeah you know live chat
thanks tom good evening councillors
ladies and gentlemen
and members of the public who may be
viewing us on
youtube my name is councillor joe manley
i'm new to this role tonight this is my
first meeting
and i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank councillor philip pennington
for all the good work and hard work that
he has done over the past years
um just to let you know there's no grand
fire drills tonight so we do get some
bells
it is quite hot um we want to leave the
building
um apologies for absence karen uh we've
had
apologies from uh phil topham and
councilman king thank you karen
okay now we're gonna go on to item
number three
which is the minutes of the last meeting
and i'll go through page by page and i
will use the
page numbers at the bottom is that okay
for everyone
yeah so page three
page four
page five
page six
page seven
hey james
a tiny bit more patient
i'll move those minutes chair thank you
counselor
councillor newton's secondary thank you
all those in favor
of staying
and any extensions
thank you public participation we don't
have any public participation this
evening
so we'll take that one off and
then when we want to item number which
is the action list
well we don't have any actions this
evening but that's kind of the reason of
this first
meeting is that we can decide
what we would like to do in the future
plan
[Music]
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest when the
item is considered
item number seven agreement of the
agenda of items part one and we
don't have any part two
paper
okay that's number seven number eight
urgent matters
brought forward with the mission of the
chair well as it's my first one i don't
have any urgent matters i don't know
about anybody else but i've had nothing
brought forward
okay right
next we do have um together drug and
alcohol service
i think the lady must be struck in
traffic so
should we go on to consideration of the
forward plan because she's not here
oh she oh she is here
um are you what do you need for your um
do you need a presentation
or just want to stand up and talk yeah
if you'd like to your white on
[Music]
so my name is joni nash i'm the head of
service and development at together drug
and alcohol service
so together drug alcohol services the
commission's
substance misuse and complex needs
service for over 18
in devon that excludes plymouth like
excludes torbay and plymouth
and what we work with is people who have
aren't it's not just
disease issues it includes complex needs
so that includes homelessness mental
health
um but we are not the mental health
service
so we work alongside the mental health
services
and there's different ones dependent on
the severity of somebody's mental health
symbols so what you've gotten available
in
courage is talkworks talkbacks
uh it's the old depression anxiety
service it's a new version
of that they are
really for people who are quite ready to
engage
in talking therapies so
if you do not attend an appointment
there is no engagement work done
they work with people on a set of
interventions
for a set period of time and at that
point you'll move
down so it's really for things
like um depression
low level depression anxiety disorders
they do not deal with larger level
mental health
issues now we'll work with people who
are working with talk works
um it's not necessarily our largest
temple of service users
because we have more complex people
so what else is available is your mental
health
treatment system so um that's the nhs
there are large waiting lists at the
moment
um they are looking at bringing in some
more funding
and the community teams work together to
try and establish what
type of funding is needed an example
being an
exeter they've just managed to secure
funding for an
outreach mental health worker to be able
to support those who are on
who are homeless so the
work that they will prioritize are um
basically personality disorders so
things that are the extreme
where there's risk to somebody else's
life or risk to us
and that's what they'll work with so as
a substance this new service
where we have people who have mental
health issues we have around 42 of our
cohort of clients who have mental health
issues
this is our biggest gap
in provision it's to do with funding um
[Music]
to do with recruitment but that is
kind of we push to have support
and what our service does is provide
interim
like psychosocial support so this
is not a therapy but we do lots of
safety planning with people
we do lots of support around
harm reduction who to go to utilizing
your family
utilizing connections what we have
established is out of the 40
of our service users who have a mental
health needs
20 of them are having their mental
health
met by their gp to the gps
have been really really helpful to
people when they cannot access service
there are some wait times of around 18
months
depending on areas so with copious
and the outcome of coverage what
it led to less people being able to move
through treatment because of the risks
that were involved
in accident than mental health children
thank you for any questions for jeremy
have you have you seen from your
perspective
um have you seen an increase in issues
of
drug and alcohol during kobe and an
increase
in the mental health problems related
during coding has there been a huge
increase which we kind of have
i don't know for sure there's definitely
been an increase
in alcohol use this is more so than
lower level
alcohol use so people who were working
who are no longer working who might be
furloughed we've seen it definitely
an increase in that and
from our service perspective coping has
meant that because we
have done more homework and easily
accessible for people
we've managed to move more people
through treatment people are having more
successful outcomes than they were
prior to covered and but for mental
health perspective
we are starting to see now that people's
anxiety are increasing
as the lockdown has lifted and they're
going back into them almost
like back into their their communities
that they're in before
and that's so we have an anxiety course
that we do with people we do stuff
around relationship work to understand
because that's the big thing
is you've been protected from those
people who you saw as family for a while
so we're doing work around that but it's
the alcohol use
and cocaine is
that are you just with adults
we do have a link with young people so
we work with um care leavers and we work
alongside weissmart
young personal service where anybody who
is a caregiver
um or 18 to 21 we hold joint meetings to
establish which service they're best to
sit in
so we look at their needs um
and then decide that way rather than 18
come to us or
and that's to make sure that we are
meeting more of their needs because
there is a different
type of engagement work that you do with
a young person what we do with nato
and it's also to break the cycle of a
young
18 year old coming into adult treatment
where you will have people who have been
intriguing for a really long time you
don't want to connect those two together
so
partly down to drink wise age while
endings and jake boys
well were set up for five years um
and they would flow from 50s alcohol
it's lower level alcohol
so what they would deal with dependency
although work alongside our service for
independence
but their funding came to an end so what
we're seeing is
people use web environment are coming
through to us
not necessarily the numbers increasing
in general but i think for us we have
recognized more about it against
impacting older people
anybody asking questions
yeah good evening how long have people
referred to me whereabouts are unengaged
so we did have an office in bedford but
we've recently moved to advanced schools
so we're at riverside court and
basketball for
north america and but we will we
satellite work out of
um center and we're just getting the
pencil visitors
to refer into us you might be coming to
the service
or you can call um and we would screen
somebody
within 24 to 48 hours what we have got
at the moment though is a waiting list
in to come in to treat them so
low level um for
really low level alcohol there is a
service for one small step
and they provide intervention so that's
the non-dependent people who don't have
any other complex needs
um but for anyone who has any complexity
and serious thinking or substance
misused then it comes to us
now our waiting lists in north at the
moment are dating back
to march so that's people into the third
end of march
this is because health and social care
as a whole
of really struggling to recruit into
those at my level
i mean you you weren't recruited to not
wonder some things
yep so we definitely work with mutual
aid and we refer people
through to mutual aid and so there's
different types of programs
um so you can get 12 steps but there's
also different types of financial aid
and they are useful to hold with free
button at the moment having them doing
face-to-face meetings
so a lot of the work that they've been
delivering is husbands online
so there is the digitally
poor people people who aren't able to
access those wonders so
those were mostly practices at the
moment um but
everything was just starting to open up
a little bit more
um to be able to see what you see
throughout the whole
thing that we saw the highest people or
people who wanted to be seen face to
face
um but that kind of group here
has been lost slightly due to not being
able to
have big enough rooms or things like
that
and if i can justify and
alcohol and drug abuse or
addiction mentally
does that cause the medical problems or
have you got mental problems people
expect and then they take content
because
mental health treatment it's a bit of
both ways
so some people substances
may have led to a mental health issue
um but for a lot of people these are
deep-rooted issues that come from
childhood or trauma that have led to
them
feeling this way it's really difficult
for a mental health
worker to provide interventions to
somebody
whilst they are still using substances
so
we work alongside them to reduce
somebody
off their slices to get them into mental
health treatment but because of the
waiting times
for a very long time at the moment to
keep them
safe and well thank you
um yeah we do i mean the mental health
services
are really helpful our success rate from
the substance has used successfully
exiting people we're one of the best
in the country um which
is really good it wasn't like that about
18 months ago but
hope is actually seems to have increased
that
but we do have a lot of people who come
back around and like successfully
access them and then they might come
around because
something else has happened to them so
we do a lot of printing
techniques um with people that we don't
provide
counselling and sometimes
mental health support there's lots of
different versions of it
here's being able to find one that suits
the process
with people which is all about using
certain tools
that doesn't work for you yeah yeah
so it's quite there's quite a gap in the
provision
but between the very serious and
the the less serious there doesn't seem
to be
an awful lot for this middle range at
the moment
so we hold what's called dual diagnosis
meetings
where we'll bring people who we feel
really needs to treat them
and we work from joint plans together to
be able to help them access that
but funding is the biggest issue that
means there's just not enough people in
the system
just from becoming
[Music]
um and mental health at the same time
we're all commissioned services
um so what we've got our dental
commissioner
is working with um the mental health
culture
to look at joint commissioning that
brings everything together
it's a challenge because it's also not
enough people coming into the field
either
so we work together on different types
of so they i provide all the information
on the kind of
referrals things like that we did one of
the examples of where we wanted to work
with everyone that was
providing like a vending machine for
needles so that when people are not able
to access services because their own
commission's mandated friday
and they were able to access that so
that's something that went through the
state of government partnership
we have really close links with um the
police in general we've got we've just
recently managed to secure
the government put out 80 million pounds
in funding for some criminal justice
work so we've just secured
370 thousands of there to
increase our provision for those really
vulnerable
to those people in prison and we're
picking them up from prison now we're
off to their management system
and to be in custody i'm in court to be
able to give on the spot
support for people on community
sentences so they're not being
criminalized
and or not having to go to prison we've
been doing
some research projects um around
what the experience is like in custody
also understanding why we have
we had 95 people in our system who've
been
on opiates for over five years who had
no
vision who had no recorded social mental
or physical health need
we can't understand why lester
um part of our discussions that we have
with the commission about our thematic
discussions so rather than just
reviewing our
apis everywhere uh one this month
this quarter is based around criminal
justice but our one next time next
quarter is around
mental health so we're looking at a
specific project
where the teams um across the county
work together
to understand the gaps in need so that
we
will do some research on where there are
certain gaps whether it impacts certain
areas more than other areas
[Music]
um
so what we see is the lower one so
that's what's really visible
it is happening in the higher ones but
there's a different thing when
when you can afford it if you like
normally you can still manage to go to
work and
so we don't get much from that
um what you're well just from the news
the people who are really well off they
go to rehab they spend a couple of weeks
for rehab and then that's it but
you don't have a home or anything else
that's what we see is it is a really
large impact
i've seen people who have presented
with one substance and they've ended up
in
supported housing housing is not
suitable
and they've developed other substance
issues through that housing
but that's all that is available so
when people are homeless on the street
actually sometimes that's safer for them
than to be in support housing for them
to fail that way
[Music]
um
[Music]
you know it's very cheap to buy alcohol
in the supermarket
and i think i rather use drugs
yeah so um the
use of the black web people are being
able to get
like drugs off the internet because of
the
small period where there is like legal
highs
that's had a massive impact because now
there's price use
people have learned how to basically
make their own
substances um and that's what that kind
of created by allowing that right legal
high to happen
alcohol is very very cheap it is
and um but what we find is most people
don't
use alcohol and drugs
that's quite rare they will abuse
multiple different types of drugs
that actually they're normally kind of
committed there's one that they love
more and that kind of takes pleasure
because i'm a
[Music]
um
oh
as you see it the linkage between
alcohol abuse and
loneliness or social exclusion
yeah so
i suppose when you haven't got
connections
most addiction comes from lack of
connection um
not having anything else to do
anything else to talk through things to
fall back on so
um but i don't think it's just related
to alcohol i think it's related to other
things as well um
but what i am seeing more and more is
just the general
your average housewife your average
worker
who's had a bad day and they're coming
home and they might be successful in
general
but they have a glass of wine and then
they're having a glass wine whilst
they're making their dinner
then having a glass of wine or something
like they finish the bottle
and then that that progression but i do
think
the exclusion and the
homeless communities actually are very
it's very easy community they interact
with each other they know each other
they've got central places where they
can go
to be with people but it is the people
that you probably wouldn't talk about
people who are using aerosols alcohol
the things that you don't have to see
very often that is happening those are
the hardest to reach people
because we know that it is happening so
you can get
free gabilan sensor dyes and hands
quite easily in the community and use
them
and that can become a very serious
health base but it's not as visible
as opioid use or alcohol use
at the extremes and with the with the
with the poor people basically so
there's a lot of unseen
addiction that is linked normally to
lack of connection question
about the funding uh you mentioned the
uh double count council's
funding but funding is not my area but
more europe
[Music]
i just asked the other counselors if
something like this is now being moved
into charge
can turridge are torrents in a position
to also
offer funding uh on the top of what
they'll be
right
[Music]
[Music]
initiative which is funded um through
storage
council and we have uh
for the hardest to reach people and
they're part of a lot wider community
city council provide us separate funding
for
certain roles that fit within their
kind of outcomes for the year so it's a
lot of short term
problems so with your charitable status
you are able
to seek your own funding yes yeah
like there is some out there now
there's quite a large amount as well my
background is
sort of fundraising and funded and
oh
yeah well this is the first council
meeting i've ever
i think i saw from your agenda that
you've got different groups coming in
and i think that's a really great thing
um because all of us kind of interlinked
with each other so i imagine
every time you're getting somebody else
maybe having a reasonably similar
conversation it'll be about a different
topic but the outcome should be kind of
the same
um i think it's definitely a start where
we can
[Music]
so we get referrals from gp's
self-referrals
referrals from hospitals families
friends
and peace professionals
often think i wish i could still he had
to share
with you
i would know about you because to be
fair i've never heard
until that's right
um we are the only commission
service so i think that that clearly
means that we think we need to do more
pushing
around what we do we work alongside gps
because we also do psychology
shared care so where gp has a special
interest
in substances they can actually provide
prescribed opiate substitute
for the person that they work in the bus
so we work quite closely with the gps
and we have our hospital liaison worker
in space in the hospital every day
and
[Music]
yeah so we went um north devon was
actually one of the most challenging
places to
[Music]
advertise we had one role that went out
eight times
um the salary isn't that competitive
because of the funding that
high so um what we did on a when we got
up from the justice funding
was we held open dates and we were
starting to come in to find out what we
did
and that seems pretty quite successful
so we've established that that's a
different way
of moving forward what we basically had
is because
we had talk wax take some of our team
somebody's name went by so they moved
out and it was just
actually getting those
[Music]
so their stability is compromised
um our staffing in north seven now is at
full capacity which is
the first time that's happened in my
whole time that i've worked with
events um so and we've got a really
great start
team and they're just starting to build
up their key stage
to be able to reduce that our biggest
waiting assignment is thank you
and this is something that's come up
specifically
in physical town councils has raised
issues about when they've been um what
we said earlier about
homelessness and sometimes to house a
homeless person
in the wrong place could lead to
further addiction or whatever certain
people have raised concerns about
several um homeless facilities
close together in your experiences i
mean obviously
they're closely wanted and people are
looking at them and they are very
careful about who they
but in your experience can can they
can it means if there are problems that
yeah yeah because i suppose
if you so we've talked about connections
when you move into a place where there's
lots of different people they
they can run reflections and therefore
you end up connecting them in those ways
it might be
a negative way um there's suitable
housing
and this is the biggest challenge i
think for housing
is to find suitable housing and stock
that isn't taken away by
private people or handle things like
that so to find suitable housing that's
something that exeter have done
is an excellent community initiatives
strategy that they've done
alongside lexus city football club where
they purchase
stock on and they have specific
type of housing this has just been built
so they'll have a house and that's
just for females who have domestic
violence
and their support will they'll have
specific people go in to offer them the
support
to keep that that's safe and then
they'll have a
dry house and you know substances people
who have managed to
come off to be to the absolute and they
will be in that dry house but they'll
have a wet house especially for people
who want to
that are still drinking or i'm still
using so being really specific
but it's it does come down to stock
one of the biggest challenges that i
think happens in exeter was
there was a bid for a massive amount of
property
and a private workforce and just out
there
and they got selected so that keeps
people
as they are um but
everybody's kind of looking at how we're
doing this jointly
what the services are starting to do now
is going how are we going to do this
together so that we're not joint
covering things
in line with our own service values and
our own service expectations
that try to streamline the services
it i mean this is a massive question
but if you could in terms of planning
and what you would say about the types
of people that may be jumping into
alcohol
is possibly very much socialized
if you could plan society and
new buildings and rebuild areas and
states or whatever
in a way that would avoid
those things what would you do
so i suppose that for me it's more about
building the things that make somebody's
life more valuable outside
of those substances so community
into community things music
gardening allotments all things like
that
are things that stop people using
because they see value
in something else so actually working
more focus around work on courses
and having those environments that are
nearby
exeter as a city has a lot of that
but it's dotted around it's quite a lot
of needs to jump to get into certain
things
but if places were made where they were
more accessible
or um i used to work in sheffield and
they did something
um fortune ahead and it was a horse that
was targeted for people in the criminal
justice system
and that they would they had the uh
pensions come in who for
four weeks they would have training
around
being able to do cds being able to
have an interview technique being able
to write a letter
really poor basic skills that a lot of
people don't get as part of education
so education's about that more key
skills that we can have
they bought dwm to be able to update all
their journals for their benefits from
themselves so they've
been in focus they've brought them to
this youth service and to be able to
make
that they needed and they brought in
employers
straight away who were able to offer
them
wells so that when they completed
all of this work they were moved into a
well
their housing was secured they didn't
have to worry about any of these things
they have something to
live for rather than just not
not dying or not getting ill and those
things
that works really really well the only
site issue that you have
is the type of employers that you have
factory work or or a job like us
they're not but those people end up in
societies
loads of people end up in issues we've
had executives
lots of different people when that's
what they're left with
so being able to
[Music]
real basic skills where people used to
leave because you need to give them a
pack for them
just the things that you absolutely
forget that you need
so to pick when you're just left with it
or you
just come out and mess with your left
foot
so there are it
so the person i worked with had a really
great job
they um had worked their way up they
worked as a laborer
every weekend they were going out and
drinking and doing cocaine and then that
led to them being criminalized because
they would get they started solving
and so i worked with them around being
able to reduce and actually what i found
was
the reason he was in it that's why
that's what happened that's what
happened
i decide friday knockoff at two o'clock
and everything just goes on he wasn't
really enjoying his job he just knew
that he's worked hard
to get him so we we worked on the things
that made him happy and it was art
so he did some stenciling forces and
then
we worked with his short trust and got
him
his health and safety certificates and
then
he got him an apprenticeship and he's
now a tattooist
and he's not using he's not drinking and
it's
wasn't because of a switch
in some days because their life changed
something that's more desirable
than what they're living in and that's
it what we do
or what the system is to really keep
people alive
but not to live
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lovely thank you
[Music]
that's for sure
anybody got any comments they'd like to
add all that or
no for me obviously
some of these things i've been talking
about i know that there are
when people
[Music]
do a bit more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and she didn't directly say
is to scrutinise our external services
and um as council parenting has taught
me it's a two-way thing
we are scrutinizing them but then we are
also asking them
what can we do what would you like us to
do
you know is there anything we can do
cats will ever ask a question
um i mean hopefully some good will come
out you can send us some funding
um
[Music]
i i don't know what what i've not seen
that name
advertised but you see edp everywhere
and it was only halfway through that she
came out with that they were actually
linked to edp you know and
the jobs that have been advertised have
been edp i've seen them
we've not been together drug and alcohol
service
she's certainly known for her staff
um
and something that she did mention which
i was pleased to hear is
lots of various services that do
similar things and now realizing they've
got to come together
and cut out the duplication that seems
to have gone on
yeah with some of these services very
often
so that
out of turn now just checking some facts
with jan here but
when we get these presentations
sometimes
it might be useful to
hear from our own side where they fit in
as well
because actually just chatting with jan
here i wanted to confirm
here in carlton i wanted to confirm that
the official service provision
requirement where they're a commissioned
service
which is county council level um
delivery so there's
that's not territory that we can move on
to as such
because somebody else is charged with
delivering it doesn't mean we can't help
and but jan then turned around and said
but we're working with him all the time
well if that's the case i don't want to
put down on the spot but
there's value to us surely because we
don't we don't necessarily know
and quite understandably we don't
necessarily know the detail
of what our officers are getting away
doing on a day-to-day basis but they're
not having to hang around
looking after us and um the
it would be beneficial for us to perhaps
have heard
what our side is doing alongside that
presentation
and then we actually learn more about
actually perhaps
quite a few of our concerns are already
met because we learn that
we are actually dealing with many of
these uh and there is
um so i just i just say that sometimes
although we're looking externally
it might be looking externally but yes
if we have the relevant officer lead
come and actually also comment on what
we're doing
and then it produces a more joined up
picture for us
and perhaps a more accurate picture
because at the moment
from the good latest presentation we
could be left thinking that
there was actually nothing being done
well it
appears quite a lot it's just sorry so
if i could jump in there and we do work
very closely
and with um together in a number of
different ways
there's two aspects to the
drug and alcohol services we um
have meetings with them from the
safeguard partnership um
from from that that community safety
side so that's really about the impacts
of drug and alcohol use
but there's also the public health side
as well um
and i mean some work that we've done
recently the uh public health team uh
county uh putting together an alcohol
strategy
and for for devon which obviously as a
commissioner service
that together we're going to be very
closely involved with
so we have those sort of um choices
strategic inputs
so we work with the the directors and
the managers
of together to understand how their
service works
and some of their needs how we can try
and tie them in with with the services
with local
services all of these sort of things but
on a day-to-day
basis all of my staff all the other
staff who
um work in homelessness housing options
the enabled enforcement guys anti-social
behavior
they know the the the staff are working
around
so they will provide direct referrals in
or they will encourage
and clients who appear to have issues
will say to them look there's
the support out there so we'll do those
referrals and handle
people and through that service as well
so there's a lot of
frontline training that they're together
uh doing for
for for our staff so they have an
understanding
of the treatment pathways because
there's a number of different treatment
pathways depending
on whether there are um a heavy alcohol
user light alcohol user
uh motor pathway and also a chronic
pathway as well which tends to be for
and those who are
long-term addict on left and build
programs and because to be honest i
think even they realize that they can't
get
those clients through in their normal
target of
12 weeks but you know through all of
these different ways
we have lots of uh contact with
commission services and
it's interesting you're saying that you
don't you've not heard of them that's
really frustrating you know we can do
our best to try and
raise the profile and but if there's any
more that you think of
doing to get that information out there
then then then please let us know but
it's
it's interesting what you're saying
about funding you know
i'm sure that they will be happy to have
more funding i think the next meeting
we've got people from the best of the
news side
and you're going to be saying the same
thing with them so
it's a very you know that it's it's a
very competitive market there's a lot of
need out there
and there's only so much we can do but i
feel that raising the profile
and helping front line
staff and i i and actually i include
members in terms of that that frontline
you know people would be with the public
on a day-to-day basis
if we can raise awareness with those
people and then
and then hopefully that will get out of
residence and they know that that
actually
that support is out there for them if
they need
it sure i was on the turran's website
this afternoon trying to find something
it's a nightmare trying to plan what is
after now
i think we could make a lot more use of
our tourist website beautiful things
like chad's just been
talking about where you can go on there
and there are various
groups like this group and it's there
and how do you get home with them
because
as i said i'm going to click contact
it's almost like we could put another
tab on this and
support community support or
this new platform will make things a lot
easier to search but i mean if you if
you have
um problems to be honest
is is tbc website the first place you
can go to google
so you know um but it's it's how we can
how we can get that information out
there actually into the communities
um but yeah i i do agree that our
website
is um it's working for myself
well we haven't got a youtube because
youtube state as well right
okay um thank you for that councillor
move in so i think it is a good
suggestion
and perhaps at the next committee
meeting which is in september
we'll look at bringing someone from our
team that's relevant to what's not going
to be on the agenda
so we've got the two sides and it may
encourage them to link up more as well
and find out more information about each
other again this is about two-way
conversation
two-way sharing information so i think
that's a really good idea
thank you
moving on to consideration of the
forward plan
now this is kind of like over to you
guys really what do you want to see
what do you want to do what do you want
to have a look at
i mean we've just come through oh well
you know we haven't come through
we're coming out of we're doing whatever
out of a pandemic you know is there
anything that we want to look at
on you know moving forward
people coming out back out with lockdown
removing of social guidelines social
distancing people going back into work
is there any particular hot topic that
you would like
we do have quite an mp4 plan
so this was kind of the main reason for
tonight really was to
get some of your ideas what you would
like to see
on this forward plan going forward
um
[Music]
and how uh
um in that direction
i also think we've got two contacts um
coming up
which is some ledger services
next year um
um
[Music]
i would like to know or get some
feedback at some point about the play
strategy
about how it's going so i know it's
there and i know it's being worked on
and
everything but i i want to know
how it's going i think that's for
external am i right saying that
is that internal well i asked incheon on
a lace-up external
oh
so maybe he can come and and explain
that and talk about that
i think it's bad i think it's internal
and external i don't think
it's you know you couldn't go join up
no it could be risky
and then sean did some better work we
did some more
flesh without and we made some
recommendations that seemed to get
ignored
particularly about having a maintenance
budget there
and then it seemed to be
we did
[Music]
october then obviously the environmental
one back to november
yeah we can't believe that one can we
driver he joins us on september or he
goes to november
what are your thoughts uneasy
charlie she'll burn in patching oh my
god
well if they've got anything to report
in september that would be great
and nasa will approach it from there is
that all right
yeah i'll get i'll get an update i'll
ask tomorrow in fact i'll email now and
i'll see
yeah if there's an update in
because we don't want to take the
illness away from the data and
[Music]
[Music]
i checked um we're talking about the
clay strategy which
really was about children's playgrounds
really
playing areas like that the other thing
is
it's a larger place spaces that we are
there's a difference of intelligence
sports fields
things like that there is a difference
i've got a big reporter
at home that was only done jointly in
north carolina
looking at the provision of sports
fields muggers all the rest of them
and we're sat here i couldn't touch them
so that's something
really i think should we get together
anybody else i'm totally new here
there's a mainly the public
independent i see there's nothing on
here about planning the views
to see how plenty of applications are
going how they're dealt with
is that something which would be on this
no that's for the plans
[Music]
um was with the health authority on the
21st
of april friday um about the sustaining
transformation program
the chair of this committee and we had
uh
steve persons there kenji was there and
the issue came back
they're very very concerned about this
we cannot get stabbed for our social
care
for our hospitals because the price of
housing is too high
and there is question that we should
really be feeding back as committee
and looking at host price issues because
when we ask what
torrance can do we are the housing
deliverer effectively
that's our place in the strategy of the
area
and we need you know when they said to
me what we
what when i said to them on 21st debate
what did you want with courage
and they said it's more cost affordable
housing
and i think we should be asking that
question and giving recommendations
to both our local developers and our
planning committee
about what is requested from our other
strategy partners
um now you've actually brought that
point up that did come up
in the housing workshop that we had last
friday
yes so one gentleman was with us it's
going to include that in his final
report
that is then going to be presented to
full council so we kind of did cover
that point
um in that workshop and i believe it was
covered in both sessions the morning and
the afternoon
so when you are talking with health
authority you say that
you you have electrical potential to
deal with that and you're not going to
turn and that was what the housing
workshop was about so
i talked about affordable whether we
were going to become potentially a
social housing provider
or look at how the local plan is to be
able to deliver these affordable housing
so that that is a big piece of work
that's on on
on its way and obviously what
consultants or the sex channel
helping us with that so there was a
notice of motion that went to call
council
i can't remember who submitted it but
that's all the interactions so
i wouldn't say for the time being want
to put it into external ons because
we've got
nothing to scrutinize because the
report's already being prepared
but uh just students know that we can't
get people down here to come
to work because the house price is too
high
in the last six months it's just
basically disintegrated
and we as a community really should be
asking questions why that's happening
i would say it's because the money is
what comes out that's the meeting
uh thanks chad with regard to uh the
forward plan
um should we possibly be
looking to identify some
certain annual or certain subjects that
we will review on an annual basis anyway
for instance
we have the police um
come to us in joint i can't remember is
that a joint joint
beating yes
likewise we've done the same with house
as well jointly
now should they be should there be other
subjects that actually
should go into the program now spread
over a year
because they are they are annual
subjects that we want to look at
because they're that's important and
what part of it we may actually refine
nearer the time
but should we be booking certain slots
in the program now
for certain things that will come up
every year and we agree that once a year
we're going to look at policing
or we're going to have an update on
policing once a year we're going to
um look uh hear from the health
authority
etc um and indeed on those occasions
our lead member for that area gets
involved as well so they can come
and and um and brief us as we as we have
had as you will recall we've had we've
had briefs from
lead members um alongside
an external um partner coming into brief
um you know
yeah i think that is a good idea the
only issue that i can
see is if this committee changes in the
next 12 months because we all kind of
swap seats
so this is my first time misty janet's
going to tell me i'm wrong
partnership report is actually a legal
requirement for cs fees to report
um to members on a manual basis and
traditionally that's been done
um that is for the past two years that
has been a joint meeting with north
kevin
only likes to do um presentation so just
to save his time it would be good
if we could if we could do that jointly
and again it's normally
um very well attended and lots of
questions so i just have
some queries about the the other items
that were on the agenda for
october and i believe it's been a single
item agenda
in the past but obviously that that's
down to members what we want to cover
in any joint meeting with
north denver council members and for the
community
partnership um on the 13th of october
so if we're going to do it you say we
should do it then no it's isn't it
it's down to members when they when they
when they have it which is more if
members are happy to have
a joint meeting with north evan um so
that that's all we only need to
um first of all
should we continue to have it jointly
with north devon i would propose
yes uh and secondly if it was on an
annual basis remind us jam when we
you know we're all getting an age we
can't remember what what time last year
did they
they reported
i would suggest that we take a take a
blank slot and try to fill it in and
that will be all of our business for the
for that meeting
sure you hope if you use your safety
partnership actually
are you thinking that maybe we should
remove environment by a sphere drainage
and put the community that is a full
meeting
subject yeah we can't put the two
together we'll be there
we'll be there for breakfast
his availability and then we can sort
that out with much better so
i'm happy to do that everybody happy
with that
before we still do the other one at some
point
does that need to be joy
but it does affect the whole noise yeah
perhaps we can get together twice a year
and then yeah
yeah so either all then let's see
what tony's availability is if you can't
do the october one let's sort them in
you know january november we got two
major ones
two close together perhaps january
nothing exciting happens in january
if he is available on october perhaps we
can move environment a bit further down
yeah we remain flexible
[Music]
because of course first responders now
to the ambulance service are very often
rescue people
and of course there is talk about the
police and crime commissioner
um taking on being in charge of all of
them
yeah you know and finally
so that's something generally but
response times are something
and how did you define
between what is inheritable isn't it
i think something will get something
from myself
yeah totally understand that yeah when
we when we get around to it
i suggest that we also um
include a report or representation from
the air ambulance
those of us who live out in the rural
part of
um i know that here in the in the towns
you can't use it but it's
it's forever buzzing in outer villages
once twice a week yeah so um the
don't forget there and i'm talking about
the ambulance service because um
it's a major part of the service
okay thank you so
we don't have any part two tonight so i
don't think i need to explain to the
public
so that leads me to confirm the date the
next meeting which is
the first of september at 2pm everybody
okay for 2pm
and then i'd like to thank the two
gentlemen
kent i was a little kenton um joining us
this evening
and we do hope to see you again
it's the projects this night yeah okay i
wanted to step down did you send me the
um
any longer at one point he hasn't
stepped down
he was just having a temporary half at
that time he's gone over
well i'd like to thank you all for
coming historic so hot i am absolutely
melbourne